l'affaire à émue jusqu'au ministre de
l'Intérieur un rassemblement de soutien
et d'ailleurs prévu ce mercredi soir
devant la caserne Chassagne à Tours
vendredi dernier en marge d'une
manifestation de lycéens quatre
sapeurs-pompiers ont été prises à partir
par un groupe de jeunes des agressions
physiques et verbales dénoncées de
toutes parts et qui ont donné lieu à une
interpellation retour sur les faits avec
Florent Clavel
la scène ne dure que quelques secondes
près du lycée Balzac les pompiers
viennent d'intervenir pour des feux de
poubelles et des recycliste à se relever
après avoir été bousculé au sol c'est là
que l'un d'eux en prise avec un jeune se
retrouve lui-même projeté par terre un
attroupement se forme et sa dégénère les
pompiers essuient des coups de pied et
de points choqués légèrement blessés il
bénéficieront de deux jours d’été
Anthony Chauveau était de garde ce
jour-là j'ai entendu à la radio le
message de mon collègue qui appelait
qui demandait une patrouille de police
en urgence parce qu'ils étaient prêts à
partir par par des individus lors de la
manifestation 72 heures après les quatre
pompiers agressés trois hommes et une
femme ont repris le chemin de la caserne
et sur les réseaux sociaux des milliers
de messages de soutien et d'indignation
de citoyens de politiques notamment le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
soutient et prompteur rétablissement aux
quatre blessés pour Anthony Chauveau
l'uniforme n'est parfois plus suffisant
pour protéger les pompiers pour une
catégorie de la population on sait comme
si nous étions nous-mêmes l'état
représentant de l'État il s'autorise à
déverser leur haine sur nous une haine
ou une colère et facelle ce sang froid
des pompiers salués par leur patron sur
34000 interventions 12 plaintes ont été
déposés cette année dans la moyenne
ce sont essentiellement d'ailleurs des
plaintes pour pour agression verbale
fort heureusement la plupart des gens
entre guillemets même si c'est déjà
normal s'arrête à des insultes ou des
menaces et